so just jumping right back into it John
Olivia when you think back forty years
to Greece what's the first yeah when I
went to swallow the 40 what's the first
thing that comes to mind Olivia because
she was my favorite and you were really
instrumental I hear in actually getting
a little cast early no one else I mean
because if you're a young man and the
seventies and I'm sure many of you were
out there if you remember that album
cover of Olivia with that blue shirt on
with those big blue eyes staring right
at you every every boy's every man's
dream was over I had love for that girl
to be my girlfriend so when I had their
the privilege to have input on the
casting I said there is no other person
in the universe other than Olivia and
John to play sandy you must cast her so
I held tight didn't I yep and I got my
way look at that what no I definitely
wait and is it true Olivia that they
they try to get you do an American
accent but you struggled with a little
bit so you decided to to make sandy
Australian actually I struggled with
everything I wasn't I really wasn't sure
I wanted to do the movie because I had
made a movie before in England which was
a musical and it didn't work so I was
very frightened about doing a movie in
my musical career was doing okay so Alan
Carr had talked to me and I said I don't
know about this and then they sent John
to me me and who could say no right this
gorgeous guy walks up my driveway these
bright blue eyes and he was so sweet and
melted me and he talked about it in hell
and I said but I'm 29 years old how can
I be 18 I look fat I can't believe I was
thinking that anyway it's all relative
right girls so he talked to me and said
you know it's all right none of us are
gonna be 18 we're all gonna be 20 I said
well I'm not sure about this but you
know I think if we did a screen test and
I could see that maybe I can pull this
off it'll work so we did a screen test
and Randall helped us through
and thank goodness you did that thank
you
and Randall you know you knew from the
moment when you saw it yeah when we did
the test it was clear because John was
John and I were sort of like making sure
that Olivia felt comfortable and and all
through I think you'd treat it almost
like a little sister right helping her
through that exactly I had other designs
but sister spine says
[Laughter]